on dit volontiers il fait aplatir il
aurait voulu cacher qui a été leur
marabout la paix bonjour à tous je
m'appelle et hui et je fais des vidéos
sur youtube voici morgan alias clip
gypsy et aujourd'hui on va vous emmener
avec moi faire une saisie dans un
élevage de chiens qui ne respectent pas
les normes et on va vous montrer le
suivi la deuxième dit que va lui offrir
une association là on s'en va dans le
centre de la france avec la fondation 30
millions d'amis on va faire un sauvetage
d'une trentaine de chiens
on est sur un truc assez fort donc on
s'attend à voir des bêtes qui sont
peut-être mal nourris peut être très
sale peut être avec des maladies dans
des espaces très restreint donc on y va
un peu avec de l'appréhension an mal an
mes collègues
et d'un état des lieux qui entend ce
chien sûrement les portes et on attend
localement qui s'ouvre avec plein de
cages à l'intérieur pouvoir en marquer
les chiens et les importants ont reçu le
grammy dans la foulée
[Musique]
pour le pôle a tout nettoyé donc ce
qu'on voit c'est choquant de guinée mais
imaginez qu'il ya quelques jours en
arrière c'était c'était bien pire que ça
genre ici il y avait des poker est
arrivé dans leurs excréments et là
tout est propre et on n'est pas monté
encore reçu et
et tu apparemment c'est là où c'est le
pire et c'est là où les chiens vivent
que sur du béton l'époque son petit
c'est que des malades il est où vivent
ta vu dans les collèges au niveau
d'hygiène
tous les matins les ars et nettoyer des
poudres et quand tu regardes l'intérieur
du foyer qu au moins plusieurs semaines
il ya c'est pas du tout aux normes les
chiens loups sur du béton n'attends rien
pour s'allonger quelque part ils sont
pas isolés du froid parce que on est au
centre de la france donc l'hiver il fait
très froid et la neige est rien du tout
pour eux pour s'être isolé de la
fondation pense qu'ils ont là géré dios
et des verts et c'est hyper contagieux
pour pour tous les autres animaux qui
sont en hauteur et normalement quand un
animal up à cette maladie est il doit
être dans une pharmacie à l'extérieur
pour pas que les autres à travers cette
maladie et tu peux en afrique fait quand
même beaucoup des faits par des chiens
qui sont assez maigres et qu'ils ont
quand le poil vraiment terme et à mon
avis ils ont tous la jirs dieuze là en
ce moment
je suis un peu horrifiée par le parfait
endroit glauque ça l'équipe une qui pue
la mort un carnage là-bas c'est
l'hécatombe ses cages là bas ils sont
très agités très nombreux qui n'ont pas
accès à l'eau tous communient comme ils
devraient avoir salement je trouve ça a
minima on devrait donner aux animaux
déjà ça manger à boire
[Musique]
en fait la partie qui les embarquent les
en profite pour recenser tous les chiens
qui récupère donc ils les bilans de les
avoir comme ça le mythe est une coche
comme ça en fait christiane listé pour
pouvoir entre les chalets identifié chez
un animal qui s'est plus fait au niveau
de l'oeil ou tetris consignes bagarre
entre eux nous on a un outil pour huit
mois le chantier soit effectivement je
ne mange pas les parias les autres sont
plus dominants dont ils mangent et après
le film anges et
reste on a plein de toute façon déjà là
on est à peine au début on va dire comme
pour les grands pandas
[Musique]
vous les sortez par deux ou par soir
tout le temps et ça s'entend bien c'est
des moutons sont jamais sortis de leur
boîte soucis au pire étant forfait de
leurs bottes qui sont jamais sortis en
laisse donc connaissent pas la contacter
ils sont complètement terroir et des
animaux qui en fin de compte ont jamais
été manipulée elle a fait de la
reproduction mais en nettement je pense
que sans le vouloir et du coup été
dépassé après là on est quand même dans
lequel tient qui tuent les animaux
la suite m'a menti au contraire l
inverse deux réseaux alors on est
vraiment dans une notice on est
complètement fiable
un vrai travail derrière pour le refuge
pouvoir enfin de social est situé à
l'animal par rapport à l'homme il ya un
parfum dans les deux sens mais bien
compte entre termine en procès enfin
c'est un chien on ne va pas aimer les
femmes et en fin de compte qui terrorise
et apparemment des cloîtres tiens il
aplatit
il aurait pu lui on sait rien qui a été
on lui remet arabe et la tête
[Applaudissements]
c'est hyper ce jeu j'ai commencé à
prendre un shoot la femelle la mer j'ai
un peu ces affaires là au moins ils
auront pas eu la vie dure pendant
longtemps les garder dans mes bras
y a pas franchement emotionnellement
c'est le faire à l'échelon tous que les
à contretemps le petit au fait ça et
sérieuse qui cherchent le contact
je pense qu'ils n'ont pas trop
l'habitude l aube six ans dormait
vraiment beaucoup
c'est hyper difficile de lieu de les
laisser en paix même si c'est pour le
mieux je sais que c'est pour lui un
procès juste sur le moment c'est hyper
ses violons quoi ouais c'est un peu
violent mais bon tu et à toi je m'y
attendais un peu mais attendez là tu
peux pas contrôler maintenant c'est bon
ça lui les pépères
ça c'est une preuve aussi de qu'elle
n'entretient pas du tout ces chiens et
qui sont regard en dit long ambitions
pas du tout en voyant garder hull les
yeux de plus qu'israël [ __ ] t'as
l'impression qu'il découvrait encore
[Musique]
dans le refuge des amis on va descendre
toutes les cages et tout voir tout les
belles maisons et passent pour du beau
demain je tenais revisite toilettage
comprend les quitte à passer la première
étape ils vont être confrontés à leur
nouvel environnement
on va porter les cages on va se
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on va les emmener directement dans leurs
bottes
[Musique]
c'est mon agressivité qui t'arrive quoi
tout est clean tout est propre
ça rien à voir maintenant vraiment on se
rend pas compte peut-être à l'image
m'estime très glop je m'attendais
franchement moi je suis je suis un peu
marqué maintenant ce qui va être dur si
je laissais pas tant que danseuse robot
[Musique]
bonjour je craque alors on s'est
reconverti en a à tous vivre ici avec
eux
[Rires]
alors on vient vous voir parce qu'on
saisisse échoué à peu près deux jours et
voir si les avait d'autres problèmes et
ils ont bien mangé depuis
alors ils sont pu être le relais ouais
parce que la personne qui les avait lavé
ses parts italien d'accord claude
pinault lors donne du mini pupilles de
la dea en complément et en voulait
savoir justement si c'était suffisant ou
pas s'il fallait changer d'alimentation
bio bon a priori qui monte
je pense que si on veut vraie celle qui
fonde le faire un petit peu plus de 400
x ya quand même beaucoup
quand il ya des sauvetages comme ça
c'est c'est quoi les premières choses
que vous regardez au niveau de l'art
sans terre parce que le parasitisme en
général keen a évoqué ses problèmes de
malnutrition dans les écoles en général
j'essaie de leur donner à manger quand
même style parasitisme aussi bien les
plus c'était délicat les parasites
internes
on te laissera assez âgé pour être
identifiés et bien l'animal soit
identifié vos ambitions que je confesse
bien rêvé pour un homme qui me ressemble
et ensuite la loi qui que pour donner ou
vendre un animal doit être identifié
telle obligation égal
[Musique]
elle vérifie d'abord a déjà eu un
mauvais moment à passer
[Musique]
tu pourras charles et son frère tu as
fais moi pas remercier beaucoup entre
eux
merci merci
tout début quand on a vu les chiens on a
dit on aimerait trop secrètement leur
donner un prénom chacune et là on a le
droit mais du coup du coup à cibles où
la femelle et hors cac c'est bien ton
prénom
tu m'en veux déjà ça sur toile de
parents ça
[Musique]
d'exercice il là on a fait des
injections de partir à l'abattoir et
d'anti douleurs
ça va pour les accès que la pac darko
quelles mains ça s'est pas améliorée et
vaches et des taupes wells comme devant
on emmène les chiens qui ne l'a guère
davantage d'argent dans le fait trop tél
alors le souci c'est petit bonhomme là
pourquoi la rue des couvertures parce
qu'il est des chiffres avaient déjà mal
c'est pour ça qu'ils ont les petites
lumières chauffante à etoy ses bienfaits
castagnet
sa patte je pense que c'est une luxation
mais parce que j'étais en échec dernière
sûr que la voiture ou autre chose
laval a bel et bien
yeah
les très très très abîmées alors qu'on
est très maigre
parce que c'est un mépris c'est ouais
les les élevages qui s'en occupent mais
en va-t-il veulent juste et qu'elle pas
élevée qu'elle fasse des bébés qu'elle
fasse des bébés ils suivent pas les
normes de reproduction et de l'espace
entre chaque porteur et ça donne
vraiment des chiens très usés dans cet
état là le bien-être du beurre mais vous
produire produire pour faire de l'argent
et n'a pas inquiet agressif ok surtout
ce qui a nous avait dit qu'il y avait un
risque médian ils sont tous en manque
d'amour
demande que ça venez tous dans les
refuges venez venez les adopté parce que
ils méritent tellement d'avoir de
l'amour et de sortir 10 sièges
non un cellulaire ouais bah du coup vous
avez tout un travail et à faire de lui
apprendre aussi à à aimer un jouet être
un chien à l'étude
[Musique]
c'est sûr c'est pas un chien qu'on va
acheter dans une animalerie ou un
élevage s'est pas lassé 1h un chien
qu'on adopte avec un lourd passé mais il
ya déjà un peu effacé ce qui lui est
arrivé auparavant mais faut beaucoup de
patience
ne pas se permettre de prendre un animal
puisse faire bâtir pour 15 jours bat
finalement jean refuge au revoir à notre
place et un responsabilités en fait oui
mais l'ancien adoptive
il ya des gens peut-être qu'on jamais eu
d'éléments dans leur vie safra qui
peuvent avoir un lien fort et créer
quelque chose d'unique ça trahit pas un
animal jamais
parce que ben hassine toute la journée
on nous balance de l'horreur toute la
journée qui est réel et l'irréel ces
trois mots la balance tout cas j'en ai
verne oublie aussi de mettre en avant en
fait ces robes longues en fait qu'il
faut le bien et qui est heureux donne
confiance et moi c'est ce que je retiens
de tout ça c'est que il ya eu un
sauvetage qu'on avait tous des caps et
ça fait longtemps que j'avais pas eu la
sensation de faire quelque chose de
vraiment bien et si vous aussi vous avez
envie d'aider pouvait venir donner des
couvertures au refuge parce qu'ils et
tous les jours il ya des couvertures a
changé c'est des petits trucs comme ça
qu'on sait pas et si vous avez envie de
faire un petit geste sous un gros geste
comme par exemple devenir bénévole et
sortir des chiens ou faire des câlins
des chiens aller dans le refuge le plus
près de chez vous ai demandé qu'est ce
que vous pouvez faire vous pour pour
aider s'il s'est pas forcément des dons
et
et on vous aiguillera sur plein de
choses que vous savez pas forcément mais
qui sont des petits gestes mais c'est
énorme pour les aides pour les roches
[Musique]
m